you can punch above your weight class if
you can aim high i mean
higher than 4x of what you thought your
goal should be if you're thinking about
raising 20 million you want to think
about 80 million if you're thinking
about building a company with 2 million
in revenue you want to think 8 million
revenue the moment you start to aim high
as a first step
you are forced
to find ways to now make it happen
you're going to find unconventional
approaches you're going to find ways
that you never thought about before
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders this one is
all about leadership meet tanvir bengu a
number one best-selling author acclaimed
speaker and team coach
he is a former digital executive and
college football national champion today
tanvir helps leaders worldwide build
championship teams in disruptive and
uncertain environments hanvir's latest
book the pro business mindset how to
lead amid disruption in chaos breaks
down his unique leadership framework
this framework helps tenveer win
championships in the boardroom based on
what he had learned on the football
field tanvir gets quoted in major media
outlets and often teaches guest lectures
in leading business schools
well
how does 10vr get to work so much about
leadership although also you know even
before thinking critically about solely
leadership more you know from an athlete
and and an executive in tech what is
sort of your trajectory in this regard
yes you know a lot of people ask me that
question and i usually start off with
um how i play football
in university
so i played um college football in
canada at mcmaster university
and that's really where i started i
think i didn't know that time that all
the stuff that i'm seeing here and
learning
uh is you know pretty much had a lead in
business until many years later
and so what happened was i graduated so
we won a national championship
in my fourth year um from a team that
had uh average record to being the best
in the country
i graduated um went on to work corporate
after my mba and i started you know
asking myself these questions what was
so great about the football team
and why are some teams in business also
great but some not so great even though
we have all the money the resources
and all the strategies right the decks
and the powerpoints
um
many years later
about a few years ago or 2019 2020 i
looked back at my career and i was able
to get
promoted pretty quickly i was a vp of
tech in my 20s
and when i look back i saw something you
know striking i said well
what allowed me to do all these great
things in technology with no tech
background
and it was never anything about
technology it was actually
a lot about the things i learned in
football for example
building your foundation spending time
when nobody's watching you to prepare
for the year ahead um or you know
working with difficult personalities
working as a team towards a common goal
um so that i say you know what that's
pretty interesting um and then i started
to implement these same strategies
in the teams that i was leading and same
thing we started seeing a lot of success
and so that's really what allowed me to
go from football to corporate
um to executive and then finally i said
well i want to find a way to share this
message
with the world
and that's where i am today where i
wrote the book
and i'm actually helping companies now
implement these strategies
well let's dive deep into the pro
business so what does that mean and what
what is pro you know besides a pro from
from an athlete perspective what does it
stand out for you
yeah so the pro business mindset um it's
a concept it's three different things so
the pro
p is for all the athletes out there or
sports fanatics p is the playoffs for
the postseason
where you're actually competing for the
championship
r is the stage before that which is your
you know regular exhibition matches or
regular season where you're actually
having the the games and the round
robins
and the o is the off season now the off
season is the part that none of us see
as spectators it's when the teams are
building their teams out
working working out training
reviewing their strategy building the
playbook for the year to come so now
that framework is exactly what i've you
know put in business and said well any
business before you can do either a
digital transformation project
build a new team lead a new business do
a new merger acquisition um campaigning
it has to start with the old first you
have to put in the work in the off
season
for example building your teams that are
adaptable
getting buy into your vision
then
you go to the regular season where you
actually have to execute there's a lot
of noise a lot of distractions how do
you know what are the right actions to
take
every single day every single week so
finally you get into the playoffs where
you have to be able to adjust and pivot
very quickly and also you have to know
how to make mistakes but be okay with it
and then move forward
and continue on the path so that in a
nutshell is the pro methodology
that
i've written the book on and also
you know i implement or run a lot of
business
workshops through as well
so where are some of the pitfalls that
have you know you're observing where you
know people would need to be guided
perhaps or would benefit from getting
guidance on these exact on these exact
principles what are the sort of pitfalls
that you're observing
yeah i'll tell you three things that
i've i've noticed um in my corporate
career even today when we're working
with a lot of the larger companies um
first of all people love to execute
without preparation
um i think we've all been there where
you know i myself i've learned this is
the hard way where i've got a project or
i've got somebody from the leadership
team tell me hey tandy i want you to go
and fix this the first thing that i
would do earlier is just go and start
working on it
what this tells us is that if you just
start doing that you actually put
yourself in a risk of failing because
you don't have the right
um the right tools the right resources
the right processes
to help you long term for example
let's say you have to do a big digital
transformation project
if you just start executing on it what
happens is that you actually end up
without any relationships without any
change management
without any buy-in from leadership or
people around you because you all know
that for you to be successful
it starts with buy-in and it's really a
change project today and you also don't
have the ability to work on your own
work-life balance because sometimes
these projects take time and if you
don't put in the work to make sure you
you personally are set up
to handle the demands in the future
you're not going to go very far
so that's one of the pitfalls is instead
of just executing
work on building the right team
work on your own personal health
work on the right playbook that'll make
you adaptable and then
you execute so you almost go slower to
go faster that's the first pitfall that
we're seeing
the second pitfall is that when things
get really tough
in execution
that's when a lot of products fail
projects don't fail because
strategy
it's because we can execute through the
roadblocks
so for example
we've got a great strategy we're going
to go implement this new technology or
this new project build this new
restructuring of our organization
but when you're the rubber hits the road
you're going to get people that say i
don't want to change you're going to get
things that you never
knew
existed in that that are now roadblocks
and you're going gonna get noise people
gonna doubt your strategy they're gonna
doubt whether you're a great leader
therefore we have to put in the right
methodologies and processes in place
that allow you to execute when things
get tough it's easy to do it when things
are easy but when things are against you
that's when you really need to tap into
the what i call is put on your
headphones
and focus on the 20 percent that'll get
you 80 of the way there
i love it and so if we're looking now
you know a bit more tangibly at the
world and and how we can see these
things come into play in the real world
i think would help me to understand a
little bit more tangibly
where are we observing these principles
these pitfalls and and these nuances
that are so critical these 20 that
elevate us to the 80 percent out here in
the real world
yeah you are you can look at these
probably in any industry today
especially after the after the pandemic
um starting off with industries that are
traditional so industries that were
brick and mortar that were
80 90 of their revenues came from
traditional channels right these
companies have a way of
executing their operations their
strategies their teams
are all built with the old business
model in mind
now what we're seeing is companies are
trying to become digital first companies
which means that your revenues
are now starting to come or they want to
have their revenues shift
from brick and mortar to digital
revenues
which is what a digital transformation
is now
what happens when you are trying to do
that is you actually are facing with
resistance you face with people who
don't want to adapt you face with
strategies that are not nimble enough
and you face
roadblocks that say well whoa you were
doing something like
the old way
now you want to do it the new way it's
not going to be so simple unless you
actually change your foundations so
really that's the probably the root
cause of why a lot of these things
happen and one of the reasons why i
think the pro methodology works so great
is because sports teams
are also operating in what we know as
change
disruption
chaos uncertainty you can have the best
plan you can have the best players but
the moment somebody gets injured in the
first quarter or the first half of a
soccer game what do you do now you still
gotta play the game
and that is what business today is
becoming more and more like it's like a
very similar analogy to a sports team
and if you can learn the principles of
how sports teams get their players
for example they're okay with turnover
they know some people are going to
retire
but they have the right people in place
to step up the next year
if businesses can start thinking like a
sports team a lot of these issues get
solved automatically
i love it so so let's say that i'm you
know i'm facing a difficult situation as
a young entrepreneur i'm leading a
startup of let's say 10 15 people and
and i'm approaching you know i'm
approaching a maybe a fundraising round
that is difficult or that the product
that i'm building is not getting the
right traction what are some
non-intuitive things that i can do with
the pro-business mindset that will allow
me and my team to overcome this obstacle
in a way that i wouldn't have been able
to do otherwise yeah
is a great question it has to be
applicable right which is which is the
whole point of this methodology the
first chapter in the first stage of the
off season michael is called aim high
punch above your weight class
what we've seen is that if you can punch
above your weight class if you can aim
high i mean
higher than 4x of what you thought your
goal should be if you're thinking about
raising 20 million you want to think
about 80 million if you're thinking
about building a company with 2 million
in revenue you want to think 8 million
revenue the moment you start to aim high
as a first step
you are forced
to find ways to now make it happen
you're going to find unconventional
approaches you're going to find ways
that you never thought about before so
it actually takes you out of
the box
that we've been put in to think like
somebody else did or what we thought is
possible
it allows you to do things very
differently that you never thought were
possible that's the first thing you have
to open up your your whole mentality
could that also backfire on us if we if
i know that i have one route that i
would take in order to reach two million
dollars arr yeah but now i'm saying well
but i really do want to get to eight
million so i'm gonna i'm gonna drop this
idea and i'm actually gonna go all out
on this new risky
go big or go home mentality could i also
find myself in a position where i
actually now have nothing because i and
i could have had 2 million error in the
first place
that is definitely possible which is why
we have to also build a playbook which
is the second concept
to getting there so once you aim high
you have to say
what are the actions that i'm willing to
take today that will actually help me
get there
and those actions have to align to your
overall goals if you put in place the
right objectives the right actions the
right teams and then which is the
regular season now you can actually
align on the overall execution
and the actions you're taking on a daily
basis
that should not happen
it will backfire if you say this is my
amazing new goal
and you basically change your entire
strategy to go after this this goal
which is not realistic
has to be realistic
but you have to have a playbook
that allows you to get there and the
idea is that if you can aim high you're
going to find ways to achieve that
overall arch overarching goal
that will at least help you
get to some place along the way
uh if not that eight million dollars
you're right that makes sense now as
you're looking at the different
organizations and leaders that you're
working with today you know where do
they benefit really most what where's
sort of the aha moment that they get as
they're going through this this business
mindset what are what is like the switch
that goes off in their in their mind as
you're observing their growth here
yeah it's it's all about um you know
believe it or not it's all about the
mentality and how we how we look at our
business
um this is nothing less rocket science
you know people have talked about this
before
this is not a breakthrough
methodology that nobody ever knew this
is what great leaders always do and
when we are talking you know in a
keynote or a workshop for all these
companies
the first thing that they always say i
have to is hey this is common sense
these are the things that i should be
doing but i'm not for example
why are we not celebrating
the small efforts every single week
even though we're not getting results
right away
as we know that today's environment
results take years
you're not just going to be able to turn
around the company in a month so you
can't say i'm gonna wait until two years
to celebrate
when we tell them about hey
have you ever seen a great
football player hockey their soccer
player score a goal but never celebrate
even though they might be losing the
answer is no they always celebrate so
then i ask them the question why are you
not celebrating these small wins
that are taking you closer
to your eight million dollars for
example of of race
so that's the common sense part
and is it realistic you know in today's
environment where people are so
triggered by these different
news outlets and we're seeing all the
hype in the media of what's whatever's
happening unless we are fed this
immediate gratification unless we're fed
these big stories it may not be
intuitive for us to celebrate yet
because it hit it hasn't hit the media
yet what can i as a leader at this point
then
communicate to my team to be able to not
just force them to sort of celebrate it
by raising a glass but actually to get
them to understand that we've done
something very special here even if it's
just micro steps towards the big
solution
absolutely
and you hit on the head michael it
starts with a leader right you have to
first of all
break down what are the small milestones
that you want to achieve on your journey
that starts with with leadership first
of all so you have to know
what am i doing this week that if we can
complete this action
will allow me to get closer to my goals
which is where having the playbook comes
in place
so if you can actually
have
small milestones laid out this week
we're going to meet with two new people
next week we're going to build our
presentation deck whatever those might
be once you hit those milestones that
for me is celebrating the effort now you
haven't seen results yet
but you're doing all the right things to
get you there
right and so you know
as i'm
as we're talking here you know where
where my mind is going is i'm thinking
and i'm looking at all the different
leaders that i knew that i'm saying and
then and part of what i'm asking myself
is also the intentionality behind
becoming better leaders right and a lot
of the questions that we're talking
about here you know they're they're
they're incredibly important but they
require us to stop in our day-to-day and
to reflect about how we're dealing with
things how are we celebrating how are we
being
put in these situations and coming out
of them as a team
what is your sort of mindset as to how
intentional we should be and at what
point should we stop and you know think
about these frameworks that you're
talking about
yeah so there's a concept that i talk
about and i think it's chapter eight or
nine it's called game of inches
and the whole idea of this concept
michael is that for us to actually get
better as leaders
it starts with the small things every
single day
so the first thing that i've seen great
readers do that i've learned from
um that have done great things
that i've also now we're helping people
do and we're seeing great results with
they find time
in their calendars every day every week
every month to work on the foundational
items
whether that's spending
20 minutes every sunday
planning out how are they going to
better lead their teams and tell some
sort of a story
whether that's spending 10 minutes every
day reading the news
whether that's taking a new course every
you know two months
you have to build your personal
game of inches your calendar to put in
the work consistently
you can never say i'm going to wait
until
we're through this project i'm going to
wait until we get this fundraising then
i'll go and work on a leadership it
doesn't work that way you have to find
the time every single day every single
week every single month to take care of
the foundations first
that will automatically help you become
better leader overall
i love it i love attention i think that
you know the work that you're doing is
just so cool and i'm excited to check
out the the framework myself and it's a
question that i've constantly been
asking myself how to become a better
leader and it sounds to me like that a
lot of these things that you're talking
about here are both you know there's
obviously the mindset that we have to
enter
but then there's actually things that we
can do as leaders to to improve the way
that we work as a team by harnessing
these ideas of sports teams mentalities
and celebrating those small wins working
together towards this bigger goal but
understanding being dynamic and and i
just loved what he talked about before
this the idea of goal setting and aiming
above your your weight class right and
and your and understanding that you know
if i if
one way to get out of this small box or
out of the small loop that i'm used to
is by aiming bigger and forcing myself
to come up with innovative ways and
obviously i can take i can see you know
what some of the greatest leaders in our
world have done through exactly
harnessing this mentality
absolutely and it doesn't even have to
be michael that you're trying to build a
new amazon i'll give you an example when
i when i left my corporate job as a vp
and i decided i wasn't sure what i
wanted to do in terms of
um my next steps you know i had some
ideas
but let me tell you this
if i hadn't aimed high
i would not have written this new book
this book came from my brainstorming
session that i did i remember that one
sunday where i was like you know what if
i had all the resources in the world if
i could do whatever i wanted to do
what does that look like for me what
should i be doing if i really wanted to
forex my growth and that was what kind
of led me to
what i'm doing today so it doesn't have
to be the amazon
you can do the exact same principle for
your relationships for your personal
uh growth or even just have living a you
know more fulfilled life so
it works uh business or personal
tanvir thank you so much for your time
and for your energy and effort i loved
it and i really enjoyed this
conversation i learned a lot and stay
safe and stay healthy and i look forward
to checking out the book myself
absolutely michael it's pleasure being
here thanks so much for having me thank
you
[Music]